schockbilder einer bösen attacke in den
usa
der riesige büffel wirbelt eine frau wie
eine puppe durch die luft reißt ihr dann
sogar die hose von den beinen
die horror szene passierte im kasseler
state park einem wildreservat im
südwesten des us-bundesstaates south
dakota eine gigantische bison herde
überquert dort die straße
die regeln bezüglich des kontaktes zu
wild hin sind in den us nationalparks
deutlich formuliert und werden jedem
besucher erklärt abstand halten nicht
anfassen und wenn möglich im auto
bleiben die 54 jährige besucherin aus
europa macht bedauerlicherweise nichts
davon die frau schießt fotos läuft
zwischen den tieren entlang und dann
begeht sie ihren größten fehler
sie nähert sich einem jungtier
die reaktion kommt prompt ein
erwachsener büffel geht auf die frau los
eines seiner hörner verfängt sich in
ihrer gürtelschlaufe bisons liegen
zwischen 460 und 1000 kilo menschen
haben dem nichts entgegenzusetzen
hilflos wird die frau herumgeschleudert
dann reißt ihre jeans während der büffel
zur erde zurück rast bleibt sie
bewusstlos am boden später kümmern sich
sanitäter um die 54 jährige
sie wird ins nächste krankenhaus
geflogen zum glück ohne schwere
verletzungen